Let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750 starting
today with our color from the six one five
area code.
Who's calling today from six one five.
Hi David, this is
Jack and I know this is a national area club.
I'm currently on vacation and Connecticut
visiting family.
Oh, all right, well I'll Connecticut do treating
you well.
Yeah.
Thank you for taking my call.
Um, so I had a couple of questions.
I'll, I'll make them as brief as I can.
Um, so you talked a lot out of $15 minimum
wage and that is one of, I think the top priorities.
They think the next president should a democratic
elected enact, um, uh, in Congress and in
the old law office.
So, but I see a lot of conflicting studies
like studies and say, oh, it's good for the
worker, does not reduce hours, is not significantly
sit na Daf, sorry, significantly reduce employment,
but diocese last days saying the exact opposite.
But the one thing I observed about those days
that say it's bad for the worker bad for entry
level workers is that they are, um, funded
by the restaurant industry.
But if you point that out to them, the rebuttal
is, oh, but your studies are funded by labor
unions.
So how do you determine whether a study is
actually unbiased and factual and there's
not a conflict of interest skewing?
There almost always will be some potential
conflict or bias in almost any study.
The question is to figure out, uh, is there
a particular way in which it is influencing
the results?
And with something like the minimum wage,
you can basically get whatever results you
want.
My view tends to be in looking at what I would
consider to be the most sort of disconnected
from biased funding academic type studies,
but I am seeing is that the, there is an effect
on hours and employment to a higher minimum
wage depending on how much the minimum wage
is increasing beyond it's status quo.
So in a state, yeah, date with a cost of living
and a lower minimum wage like Arkansas going
from, you know, eight to $15 is going to have
a much bigger impact than it is in a state
where the minimum wage is already, for example,
$11 and 15 arguably may not even be a living
wage still.
So there is, that's the issue that it's a
very regionalized effect that you need to
be looking much more specifically.
And just because there is some negative impact
to a policy, that doesn't mean it's a policy
we shouldn't do.
Think about how many policies we enact all
the time that have some costs, but we determine
the benefits outweigh the costs, if that makes
sense.
Jack.
That makes absolute sense.
And that was what I was reading on, um, the
economic policy institute where they were
saying that that, oh, like the, there might
be very, very small, um, cost to it, but the
benefits far outweigh it.
But then, um, the reason I was asking that
is because I saw this very interesting old
um, segment that Kyle Kalinsky did back in
2013.
I came across it recently where Chris Hayes
was talking about how there was a, uh, this
group called the Employment Policies Institute
that sounded, you know, academic and serious,
but really they were just a PR for them, for
the restaurant lobbying industry.
And he brought on the sky.
Have you heard of this guy named Michael Saltzman?
No.
Yeah, he writes lob op-eds.
I'm saying old memo age is terrible and all
the things you hear will kill jobs.
Well, that's the main point you make.
Um, but Chris Hayes is like, um, the studies
you're siding are bought and paid for by the
restaurant lobbying industry.
And Kyle was, Kyle said in his segment like,
well that's what they do.
They, they pay for fake studies to get the
results that they want and then they have
so that they have a fake intellectual life
to stand on so that they say, well, we would
love to raise the minimum wage and contract
profits, but we have this day that says it's
a bad idea.
So sorry.
Okay.
Yes they do.
[inaudible] all right, Jack, thank you so
much.
Appreciate the call.
I've got a bunch of people waiting, but I
do hope to hear from you again.